GLIMPSE AND MAYBE WE'LL HEAR
MORE SOON.
>> I'M SURE WE'LL HEAR MORE
SOON.
JESSICA, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> STUNNING NEW REPORTING
TONIGHT ABOUT THE ALARMING
TENSION BETWEEN FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND TOP MILITARY LEADERS
AT THE PENTAGON.
IN THEIR NEW BOOK, THE DIVIDER,
TRUMP IN THE WHITE HOUSE 2017 TO
2021, PETER BAKER AND SUSAN
GLASSER SAY THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF, GENERAL
MARK MILLEY, WAS ON THE VERGE OF
RESIGNING IN A TRULY SCATHING
LETTER.
LET'S GO TO OUR PENTAGON
CORRESPONDENT, OREN LIEBERMANN.
THIS RESIGNATION LETTER THAT
MILLEY WROTE BUT NEVER SENT, HE
HAD VERY, VERY TOUGH WORDS FOR
THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
TO PUT IT MILDLY.
GIVE US WHAT YOU KNOW.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS IN THE DAYS AND WEEKS
FOLLOWING JANUARY 1st, THE
INFAMOUS WALK OF PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP AND SOME OF HIS TOP
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISERS
INCLUDING CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT
CHIEFS MARK MILLEY TO LAFAYETTE
SQUARE.
IT WAS IN THAT VIDEO THAT WE SAW
MILLEY WALKING RIGHT NEXT TO
TRUMP BEFORE SHORTLY AFTER THAT
VIDEO, MILLEY REALIZES WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND PEELS OFF.
THAT, OF COURSE, IS NOT WHAT'S
REMEMBERED FROM THAT MOMENT.
ACCORDING TO THIS ARTICLE, THIS
EXCERPT FROM THIS NEW BOOK, HE
WAS TORN ABOUT WHAT TO DO IN THE
DAYS FOLLOWING THAT AND EVEN
PENNED A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
DRAFTS OF A RESIGNATION LETTER.
HERE IS PART OF WHAT HE WROTE IN
ONE OF THE VERSIONS OF THIS
LETTER.
I'LL READ THIS TO YOU.
THE EVENTS OF THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS HAVE CAUSED ME TO DO DEEP
SOUL SEARCHING, AND I CAN NO
LONGER FAITHFULLY SUPPORT AND
EXECUTE YOUR ORDERS AS CHAIRMAN
OF THE JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF,
ACCORDING TO THE NEW YORKER.
IT'S MY BELIEF YOU WERE DOING
GREAT AND IRREPARABLE HARM TO MY
COUNTRY.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE MADE A
CONCERTED EFFORT TO POLITICIZE
THE UNITED STATES MILITARY.
MILLEY AT THE TIME WAS DOING
EVERYTHING HE COULD TO MAKE SURE
THE MILITARY DIDN'T GET INTO
POLITICS, ACCORDING TO THE
EXCERPT WE'RE READING FROM THE
BOOK, HE VIEWED TRUMP AS TRYING
TO DRAG THE MILITARY INTO
POLITICS, WHETHER THAT WAS
THROUGH THE INSURRECTION ACT OR
HOW HE PORTRAYED THE MILITARY OR
HOW HE WANTED TO USE THE
MILITARY.
HE HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS,
MILLEY, THAT IS, ABOUT WHETHER
TO RESIGN.
ULTIMATELY, HE DECIDED NOT TO.
HERE IS ANOTHER EXCERPT FROM
THIS BOOK.
F THAT S, MILLEY TOLD HIS STAFF,
ACCORDING TO THE NEW YORKER.
I'LL JUST FIGHT HIM.
IF THEY WANT TO COURT-MARTIAL ME
OR PUT ME IN PRISON, HAVE AT IT,
BUT I WILL FIGHT FROM THE
INSIDE.
SO THAT GETS A BIT INTO THE
THINKING BEHIND WHETHER MILLEY
SHOULD HAVE STAYED IN HIS
POSITION OR LEFT IN HIS POSITION
AT THE END OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
ESPECIALLY AS TRUMP WAS
ESSENTIALLY CLEARING OUT
PENTAGON LEADERSHIP AND PUTTING
IN SOME OF HIS LOYALISTS THERE,
AND MILLEY WAS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HIS OWN WAY FORWARD AT THAT
POINT, WOLF.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT THAT SUSAN
GLASSER AND PETER BAKER BOTH
TRULY EXCELLENT JOURNALISTS ARE
ALSO REPORTING THAT TRUMP DIDN'T
WANT ANY INJURED U.S. MILITARY
VETERANS AT A JULY 4th PARADE HE
WAS PLANNING.
IS THAT RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND ACCORDING TO WHAT WE'RE
READING HERE, AND THIS STEMS
FROM TRUMP AT THE TIME GOING
WITH FRIENDS TO SEE A BASTILLE
CELEBRATION WHICH INCLUDED A
MILITARY PARADE.
HE WAS ENTHRALLED BY IT, HE
LOVED SEES THE SPLENDOR, THE
POWER, THE FORCE OF THE MILITARY
PARADE, BUT WHAT HE DIDN'T LIKE
SEEING WAS ALL OF THE INJURED
SERVICE MEMBERS IN THE PARADE.
HE TOLD HIS CHIEF OF STAFF AT
THE TIME, JOHN KELLY, TO MAKE
SURE THAT IN THE PARADE HE WAS
THINKING ABOUT, THAT HE WAS
DREAMING ABOUT, HE DIDN'T WANT
TO SEE INJURED SERVICE MEMBERS.
IT WAS KELLY WHO TOLD THEM THOSE
ARE THE REAL HEROES.
>> KELLY WAS RIGHT.
OREN LIEBERMANN, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
LET'S GET MORE ON ALL OF THIS.
JOINING US, CNN MILITARY
ANALYST, RETIRED LIEUTENANT
GENERAL MARK HERTLING.
HOW ANGRY MUST GENERAL MILLEY
HAVE BEEN TO WRITE SUCH A
FORCEFUL RESIGNATION LETTER AND
WHAT DOES IT TELL YOU THAT HE
DECIDED IN THE END NOT TO RESIGN
BUT INSTEAD STAY ON AND FIGHT
FROM THE INSIDE?
>> WOLF, THAT LETTER WAS
PHENOMENAL.
WHEN I READ IT THIS MORNING AS
THAT ARTICLE CAME OUT, IT WAS
OBVIOUS THAT GENERAL MILLEY WAS
GOING THROUGH AN EXTREMELY
EMOTIONAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
TIME.
HE WAS TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR HIS SERVICES, NOT ONLY
JUST FOR THE ARMY BUT FOR ALL OF
THE JOINT SERVICES AS THE
CHAIRMAN.
BUT THAT LETTER WAS EXTREMELY
UNUSUAL.
YOU KNOW, THE MILITARY DEBATES
AND IN SEMINARS AT THE WAR
COLLEGE OR LEAVENWORTH, WE
DEBATE ABOUT RESIGNING FROM THE
SERVICE UNDER EXTREME
CONDITIONS.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN OR COULD
COMPREHEND THE KIND OF LETTER
THAT GENERAL MILLEY WROTE THAT'S
PUBLISHED IN THAT EXCERPT.
SEVERAL PAGES LONG, IT NOT ONLY
SAYS, HEY, I'M RESIGNING OR
RETIRING BECAUSE I DON'T THINK I
CAN LIVE UP TO YOUR STANDARDS OR
I CAN'T DO THE THINGS YOU THINK
I SHOULD BE DOING.
IT LITERALLY POINTS TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP IN EVERY SINGLE AREA THAT
HE WAS IN VIOLATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION OR IN GENERAL
MILLEY'S VIEW, THE LEGALITIES OF
THE OFFICE.
SO IT WAS JUST PHENOMENAL, AND
I'M SURE GENERAL MILLEY REALLY
STRUGGLED WITH THE DECISION TO
STAY IN OFFICE.
>> I'M SURE HE DID.
THE GLASSER AND BAKER ALSO
WRITE, GENERAL, THAT FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP ACTUALLY ASKED
HIS CHIEF OF STAFF, JOHN KELLY,
WHY HIS GENERALS COULDN'T BE
MORE LIKE THE GERMAN GENERALS
WHO REPORTED TO ADOLF HITLER.
DOES IT SURPRISE YOU AT ALL THAT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WAS LOOKING FOR
THAT TYPE OF GUIDANCE,
OBEDIENCE, I SHOULD SAY?
>> IT DOES NOT, WOLF.
AS WE HAVE SAID SO MANY TIMES ON
YOUR PROGRAM, PRESIDENT TRUMP
SEEMED TO BE ENAMORED WITH
GENERALS LIKE PATTON, PROBABLY
BECAUSE HE SAW THE MOVIE.
HE WAS KNOWN TO NOT BE A
HISTORICAL BUFF.
HE DIDN'T SEE THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS IN BOOKS BUT HE WOULD
WATCH A MOVIE LIKE THAT AND SAY
THAT'S THE KIND OF GENERAL I
WANT, THE TOUGH GUY, THE GUY
THAT IS OUT OF CENTRAL CASTING.
BUT AS GENERAL KELLY, RETIRED
GENERAL KELLY REMINDED HIM, THE
GERMANS HAD SEVERAL INSTANCES
DURING WORLD WAR II WHERE THERE
WERE ASSASSINATION ATTEMPTS, SO
PERHAPS INSTEAD OF JUST WATCHING
PATTON, PROBABLY PRESIDENT TRUMP
WOULD HAVE BEEN WELL SERVED BY
WATCHING THE MOVIE VALKYRIE WITH
TOM CRUISE ABOUT GERMAN GENERAL